okay yeah thanks a lot sanja
and i uh i work in an area called
security this means that
besides crypto i also get to build
systems and i
i work on programming languages our
programming language group at university
of maryland
is called plum pl university of maryland
so so i work with the plumbers
and this is a little lambda and okay so
by the way i am joining canal in the
fall okay
and so the plan is
i'm going to talk about an oblivious ram
in the standard
in the classical setting and then daniel
wicks will talk about an
oram with server-side computation
including
any oram double ram and reusable gobbled
ram
okay to begin with i'll first
talk about the problem of access pattern
leakage that oram
is trying to address and i'll talk about
the different manifestations of this
problem in
different application scenarios okay
and the first scenario consider you have
a secure processor
and the secure processor you know your
cloud server
you have secret genomic data on your
cloud server and then
to protect our genomic server to protect
our genomic data
and you you rely on the secure processor
to encrypt
your memory contents okay um but the
problem is that
even though your memory contents can be
encrypted if your adversary
can observe this communication link
between the secure processor and the
memory
the attacker can still learn a lot of
information
for instance if the attacker observes
that the processor is accessing
locations
related to the kidney problem then he
can infer that maybe this user is being
treated for kidney problems
so that's very sensitive medical
information
and in the real world how do you launch
this attack
this attack can be launched in various
ways for instance if this attacker
let's say is an a system admin and
are an intruder to the cloud's data
center then he can launch physical
attacks he can
probe memory buses to learn the memory
addresses that are transmitted on the
memory buses
but this adversary can also be a
software adversary
so imagine the secure processor
you know i i will talk about the sjx
scenario later where the secure
processor relies
on an untrusted operating system to
serve page files
and in this case this untrusted
operating system is going to be your
adversary
okay so like i said in this case
basically access patents to even
encrypted data can leak very sensitive
information
okay a different scenario and it's the
same picture but now
and this instead of memory we have this
vertical cloud
and then we have the client okay and the
client is storing data in the cloud
and it's accessing the data in this case
your adversary can be
a network intermediary like routers in
the network
or maybe just let's say just the um
operating the untrusted operating system
on the client side
which is going to basically service
these network requests
okay and
there are some other settings where
um the problem is the same in nature
access pattern leakage problem although
at first sight you know you may not
immediately realize it
so so intel is going to for instance
soon release this new
uh sjx technology sjx is
going to be a secure processor that can
encrypt memory so suppose
and our cloud favorite cloud provider
amazon ec2 is going to offer sjx
as a service so secure compute as a
service
and sjx hosts the server farm you know
we have
many sjx servers running and let's say
they
run a mapreduce task
okay um so what's going to happen is
that
and and these sjx nodes are going to
communicate with each other
you can think of this as like a
distributed memory system like because
the data is going to be split across
these multiple servers and by
observing these access patterns you can
leak sensitive information
so for instance specifically in sgx you
have the mapper and the reducer
let's say the mapper you know produces
key value pairs
and and key value pairs with the same
key are going to be routed to the same
reducer
so sometimes by observing let's say how
many key value pairs are routed to the
same reducer you can gain
sensitive information about the
underlying data okay so this is an o-run
problem in disguise
and similarly uh by the way speaking of
sjx
let me and and take a slightly deeper
dive to look at
what the adversarial model is so in an
stx
the secure and the sensitive application
is going to run
inside this sjx enclave and and this
enclave itself cannot um call os
system calls so for instance if this
enclave needs to
perform um page swaps then it needs to
send the request to this untrusted
operating system
and this operating system is going to
serve these page files on behalf of the
enclave
and and similarly for network requests
as well like suppose this
in this picture uh these sjx enclaves
are going to talk to
other sjx enclave enclaves in the
network
and then these network requests are also
going to be serviced by the untrusted
operating system
okay so in this case this is a software
adversary
and the untrusted operating system can
basically observe these addresses
and be it addresses of page swaps or
addresses of network requests
um okay so here is
uh also a similar issue but the context
context you know uh replace sjx with
secure computation
so imagine you have these servers but
instead of having sjx you are relying on
secure multi-party computation
to and perform privacy-preserving
computation
and similarly you can consider the
memory as being distributed across these
nodes
and then the communication pattern here
would also similarly leak information
so this is the model that actually elect
kaimi and
rafael considered they call it an
oblivious parallel ram and then they
also
used it to design large-scale secure
computation protocols
okay and so here's
some some ways to think about access
pattern leakage
and the first perspective is from a
programming programming language
perspective
why do access patterns lead to
information because when we run programs
on sensitive data
these programs can have uncontrolled
branches that depend on secret data
in this case if the sql variable is one
you read location x otherwise you
relocation y
and think about the secret variable as
being the last bit of your secret key
so this is a bit abstract and a more
concrete example for instance is binary
search
and this is something that everyone is
familiar with
when we do binary search we are going to
look in the middle and depending on the
result of the comparison we either look
left or look right
so if you simply observe the sequence of
access patterns incurred
you can pretty much infer whether you
are searching for a small value or a big
value
okay and another perspective to
understand access pattern leakage is
from
an a statistical perspective
so you know when we teach undergrad
security we tell the students
and deterministic encryption is not
secure because of a statistical attack
and here the the reason is similar uh
essentially the attacker can observe the
frequency
and frequency of the axises and the co
occurrence like
a memory location x and tends to be
co-accessed together with memory
location y
okay so in fact and a group of
researchers from ut dallas
they actually performed an attack on the
an enron email data set so suppose
this data is start on the server in
encrypted format
and there's a client making queries to
the data so both the queries
and the data are encrypted and all the
server observes
is the access patterns and then they
show just by observing the access
patterns you can infer like up to 80
of the search and search queries and
this attack leverages background
information
on the natural language and corpus
okay so one thing to point out that
people often ask me
and this is this a side channel in many
models this is not just a side channel
like for instance insecure multi-party
computation um and
this the security definition of mpc
basically requires that the access
patterns be kept private
okay and also if you are a programming
language person and
it's also easy for me to explain why
this is not a side channel
for instance um imagine this sjx
scenario
your application is actually this sjx
application
is going to send these addresses
to this untrusted operating system
and from an information flow perspective
these addresses are going to be tainted
bits
so even if you just use the standard
information flow type system
you know if your program leaks
information through access patterns it's
not going to type check
under a standard information flow type
system okay
and so how can we secure against access
pattern leakage and we have uh
oh dad and rafi smiling at us oh we need
oblivious ram
okay this was proposed back in the 1980s
by
by these two people
okay so obvious ram is a cryptography
protocol that
allows us to hide access patterns to
data and not only so
it also hides access patterns in a
provably secure manner
okay and then since the uh the seminal
work and
by rafi and all that there have been a
sequence of and
subsequent works that improve on their
results
so i'm going to talk about how to
construct a ram
and and before i do that i want to get
some key intuition across so one key
observation is that
in any oram scheme the data blocks have
to keep
moving around and why is this the case
so imagine if the data blocks always
resided in the same place
what can happen um okay
so suppose the cpu makes two subsequent
accesses to the same location
uh and and if this data block didn't
move between these two accesses
then the adversary can observe that
there's a link ability because it
observes
that the same block has now been visited
twice
so this leaks frequency and current
information and this is kind of the kind
of statistical attack
that i was referring to earlier
so the key thing to keep in mind is
essentially every time you read the
block
the block must immediately relocate and
if it doesn't relocate like i said the
next time you read it it's going to leak
statistical information
okay so so in the initial oram scheme
that
oda and rafi propose and it's called a
hierarchical oram framework
and this is roughly uh what the scheme
looks like
and i won't have time to explain the
construction but
in the construction is is very clever
and then they achieve roughly speaking
log cubed overhead and this means that
in order for you to access one block you
have to pay
and roughly speaking log cube accesses
on average to completely hide your
access patterns
uh so so in fact actually one of these
logins it's just a minor node one of
these logins
is a security parameter so like
basically log cube
and gets you an inverse poly failure
probability uh correct me if i'm round
roughly and if you want to get an um
negligible failure probability there's a
extra little omega one
there but like in most of the talk i'm
going to just pretend we are happy with
inverse poly
failure probability to make things
easier
okay so instead i will talk about the
entry-based rams um
okay so for tree based rams you are
going to see a tree
and the most frequent uh frequently
asked question
uh by far is why why is this is the tree
upside down
so oh well when we were designing these
ram schemes we were considering the
storage outsourcing scenario where
there's the client and the cloud
and typically the client in the cloud is
in the sky
and then the client is writing into the
root bucket
so that's why the tree is upside down
and alternatively you can also draw it
in the story but then your cloud will be
underground
and then everything will be pretty much
upside down
okay but so i'm going to stick to this
convention and if you
you're uncomfortable just just tilt your
head for the rest of the talk
okay so in the binary tree oram i'm
going to first talk about
the initial binary tree construction and
then i'll talk about how to
improve this to patho ram and circuit
oram and then
at the end of the talk i'll also survey
some of the more recent results
okay so every node in the tree is called
the bucket
and the bucket has finite capacity it
means the bucket can hold
a finite number of blocks and some of
these blocks are real blocks and
other blocks are dummy blocks okay
and here's the most important invariant
of the scheme
uh every block is assigned to
a path and when i talk talk about a path
it always means a path from the root to
some leaf bucket
so here the block x is assigned to the
purple path
in the beginning i'm going to cheat a
little bit i'm going to pretend that the
cpu
is going to start a large position map
that
records where every block is okay
so given a data structure like this
reading a block is very simple
because in order for me to read block x
all i have to do
is to look up the position map and find
out
that block x is on the purple path and
then i read the purple path
and i'm guaranteed to be able to find
block
x so you're not committing where x will
be on the past it's like one of those
notes
it's any x can be anywhere and on the
path
okay and so
and the more tricky part is after i read
block x what do i do
like i said earlier every time you read
a block it has to immediately relocate
otherwise the scheme would not be secure
okay so now our job is to relocate x
and so basically x can no longer be
residing on the purple path
let us now pick a fresh new path namely
the orange path
and let's try to assign black x to the
orange path
okay so obviously we have to update the
position map to reflect this
this change what else do we have to do
obviously we have to write block x to
the orange path
and how do we do this unfortunately it's
not
okay to write x to the leaf node or any
of the internal nodes
for instance if you write x to the leaf
node and then the adversary can observe
that some block from the purple path is
now relocated to the orange path
so the adversary can remember this link
ability
okay and similarly you shouldn't be
writing to any of the internal nodes
and therefore the challenge is how you
can write the block back
or without revealing which new path it
is
and there's a way to do this
obviously and basically to write the
block into the root bucket
the root packet is on every path so it's
always unsafe to write the block
into the root bucket
okay so at this point um
so obviously if i keep doing this then
the root bucket will overflow but
this disregarding this overflow fact
let's think about why the scheme
preserves obliviousness
okay so what what happens whenever you
access a block right
and observe that whenever you access a
block you are going to access a complete
random path
and the choice of the randomness has not
been revealed to the adversary
earlier so in this sense um
the oblivious proof is trivial
okay so the remaining problems that i
need to solve
is number one how to deal with overflows
like i said
and this is bucket overflows not buffer
overflows
if you cut each bucket a buffer then you
can call it a buffer overflow problem
and then we can also we also need to
see how to and get rid of the position
map like i said in the beginning
and finally i'll talk about some further
optimizations that we can do
so how do we deal with overflows
the problem is that each bucket has
finite capacity
and you cannot keep writing things into
the root bucket and
and similarly for every other bucket as
well
um so how can we prevent
overflow of buckets for every bucket in
the tree
and the idea is that we want to
introduce this eviction procedure
okay and the goal of the eviction is to
gradually
congratulate and percolate the blocks up
the tree
towards the leaves and such that none of
the buckets will ever overflow
except with negligible probability so
there are
conflicting goals for designing the
eviction algorithm and eviction has to
happen
slowly enough such that the cost is low
so for now you can think of eviction as
happening in the background
but the cost is attracted to each access
and then the eviction has to be fast
enough such that we can prevent overflow
i'm going to talk about a very simple
algorithm for performing eviction
and and it's called the random eviction
strategy
and the idea is that every time you
perform a data access
you are going to pick two random buckets
at every level in the tree
and you perform eviction on these two
random buckets
so what does it mean uh to pick a bucket
for eviction
so suppose let's say i pick this bucket
for eviction
what i'm going to do is i'm going to pop
a block from this bucket and i'm going
to write it to one of the children
um but and the way the scheme works
remember that
there's this invariant so when i pop
back
when i pop a block and the block can
only go
one direction and in order not to
violate
the main invariant okay so so if
let's say this block is assigned to this
subtree
and then basically the block should go
right
but in this case in order to hide
information from the adversary
we also need to make a dummy eviction on
the left hand side just basically to put
up the
appearance that we are also making
eviction
on the left hand side okay
so just just keep in mind that every
block
is encrypted and when i when the client
reads the block
it will decrypt the block and re-encrypt
it and write it back
okay so if you are going to overwrite
the block and
the new cipher text has randomness so
basically
the adversary cannot see which block has
been changed
read as well because read you will need
to and
remove the block from the bucket and
which means
encrypting a dummy block you also do you
also re-encrypt every time you move it
is that what you're saying but there are
some if you actually implement it on a
secure processor there are some
optimizations you can do like
you can have a valid bit so for instance
reading will just involve and
invalidating that bit
so so you don't have to basically do
encryption on the
on the entire block so this will save
you constant factors but if you don't
care about constant factors just
imagine everything will be encrypted
re-encrypted as you write it back
so then just to check so you are like
reading something you move along the
path and somehow you decide that this
guy has to be evicted
but this is the real thing you cannot
evict him randomly you have to evict him
along his path right
so you have to put him on the right path
but you're saying you will you will make
two rights
but the real one will be along the right
path
yes so basically um first i'm going to
read back every block
in this bucket and some of them are real
some of our
dummy and i pick any real block it
doesn't matter which one i pick
and i check to see whether this block
should go left top or right and in this
case it should go
right so for the left hand side i'm just
going to read back everything and write
it back as is
but for the right hand side i'm going to
read a block see if it is empty slot
if so i'm going to write this evicted
block otherwise i
write the block back and you're saying
you do it only for
two nodes so you do also for two nodes
in every bucket uh
so with every eviction pick two random
buckets at every level
so so do it for two buckets at every
level oh it's not correlated with the
read path it's just not correlated with
repack
this is the original binary tree scheme
uh okay
yeah the root is in some sense just a
singular point the root and the kind
stash are like
more or less the same thing okay
so why does this division algorithm work
actually with with not too much work we
can show that if the bucket size is log
n
roughly speaking and then none of the
buckets will
overflow with high probability so
actually here high probability means
inverse poly if you want to get
negligible failure probability
you need another little omega 1 there
and
in the log n okay
so the idea is actually very simple why
is it log n
and the intuition is very simple i'm not
going to do the formal proof the formal
proof
is going to take a little more effort
and the idea is
we can think of each bucket as a queue
and
we just want and the the dq rate to be
like constant factor larger than the
incur rate
okay so what is the incur rate at a
level i
of the tree and
it's not hard to see that it's 1 over 2
to the i
because essentially and at every time
step one block is
going to come in and if your q
is like stable like if your q doesn't
grow unbounded then essentially the
rating
has to be equal to the rate out right so
essentially
one is there's a rate of one coming in
here and then it's split into
a half here and a half here and it gets
further split into one quarter
um so so therefore the rate the incur
rate is
one over two to the i at level i of the
tree
and the decay rate is on 2 over 2 to the
i because i pick
two random buckets at every level to
evict so therefore
this kind of informally speaking this
kind of behaves like a
a very standard mm m1q
and this is what we learned in our
undergrad probability class
and we learned that the q length and
the probability that the q length and
exceeds r is proportional to
something like you know two to the
minus r so false off exponentially
um with respect to r okay
so that that of course is not a formal
proof and because
actually these queues are dependent it's
not a single queue
if it's a single mm1q then it would have
been the end of the proof
but it's a little more tricky because
these queues are dependent
so in order to do the proof formally you
would either have to use
an uh the discrete version of the
burke's theorem which allows you to
derive an exact distribution
on the the q length uh or you can use a
turn off bond if you don't care about
deriving an exact distribution of the q
length
okay any questions
would it help you to increase the degree
of the tree
of the tree would it help and
it wouldn't help reduce
it it wouldn't help in the in asymptotic
sense
uh we i tried the different things and
there's one interesting point and which
is this
flat partitioning scheme where you only
have let's say one
one level it's basically flatten the
tree into one level but you have like
square root and partitions
with a square root and each partition of
square root and size
so that will give you a scheme where the
client side storage is like
square root n um
and then for for each partition you can
kind of imply
an o-ramp scheme for each partition and
so we actually in our recent work on
this network
network oblivious ram model we consider
a model where like each memory bank
the obliviousness within each memory
bank is free
and you can only observe which bank the
adversary is accessing so in that paper
we use this
flat partitioning technique
okay so i haven't talked about how to
get rid of position map yet
but the idea is very simple instead of
storing the position map on the client
side
i'm going to i'm going to recurse and
start the position map on the server
side
in a smaller ram and i will
keep on recursing until i have a
constant
constant position map
okay so there are some tricks in
parameterizing the recursion
and that's why and these papers like
have this dependence on the block size
so suppose your block size is like c log
n
and which is i guess what all these o
ram papers assume
and then you will have login depth
of recursion essentially every level of
recursion you reduce the oram size by a
constant factor
and after login levels you get constant
size position map
so in this case this recursion will
incur an extra log n factor
in the asymptotical bond okay but there
are other ways to parametrize the
recursion so suppose your data block is
login
roughly speaking log n squared in size
and so you use this is called the big
block little block trick
um in this and topmost level of the
recursion you are going to use the real
data block size which is log n squared
but then for these metadata levels you
use a different block size which is log
n
so you are still going to have and log n
levels of recursion
but all the metadata levels will only
incur uh
in total um log n squared cost
um
so i need to be a little careful about
what i say so let's say each tree
in the binary in the binary tree oram
case
each tree itself will incur log and
square costs
because in order to read the path i have
in order to read the block i have to
read the path and every block
every bucket is login in size and then
the height of the tree is log n
and so so therefore within each level of
recursion the cost is log n squared
okay so in this case if you do this
a little block big block trick then over
all these recursion levels in total you
incur
a log cube cost because there are login
levels
um and let's say in each level
you incur log n square costs but
even though it is log cube because your
block size
is log n squared and
and this is maybe i should write this
down
so for the binary tree
so say your block size and is d and in
the top level
you incur like d times log n square cos
and then so this is the data level
and then for all the metadata levels
added together
and you will incur d times log n
and cube oh so there is no modi sorry
there is no marty here
so so for the metadata and
levels you use a lock and block size
so you will incur this much cost in
total so suppose
d is in this case log n squared
um so as you can see basically and
in order for me to read a block of the
size the in size i have to in total
and read roughly speaking
log log to the fourth bits
so therefore the the bandwidth blow up
is roughly speaking log n squared
and therefore in this case the recursion
doesn't incur extra asymptotic overhead
okay and another interesting point is
that when the data block is very big
and you use the same block uh same block
size
for both the metadata block and the data
block
so if your block is entered epsilon size
then you have constant levels of
recursion and therefore the recursion
also doesn't incur extra
asymptotical costs
okay so this is just the basic idea for
the binary tree scheme and
we can improve the efficient algorithms
uh to reduce the bucket size to
constant like in binary tree around the
bucket size is log n
so how can we reduce this to constant
um so i'm going to very briefly talk
about patho ram
and circuit oram okay
so in particular circle orm can actually
achieve roughly speaking login
costs login bandwidth blow up
with constant cpu cache and this holds
for
um log n squared block sizes
and this actually matches the go rig
ostraci lower band
um the lower bound specifically actually
so essentially gorek ostrovsky they show
a lower bond that
any o ram scheme with constant cpu cash
must incur at least log n costs
okay and then the lower bound holds
regardless of the block size
so this matches the lower bound for like
roughly speaking log and
block sizes or log n square block sizes
and then for smaller block sizes we
don't have a matching
upper bound
okay so patho run um
this is due to emil stefanov martin van
dyken
and others the sc f r y
d part and
so python ram and the improved variants
have been implemented in two secure
processor prototypes
the ascend processor and the ghost
writer processor
so ascend is built by this team at mit
and
including uh sweeney davids and
chris fletcher and lynn run and
and others and actually for ascend they
actually sent their processor design to
a factory to be fabricated for real
so this is going to be exciting
okay pathogram algorithm is very simple
in order for me to access a block x
i have three steps right it's like have
you heard of the
how to put an elephant in a fridge there
are three steps
open the door put the elephant in and
close the door so here we have three
steps too
you you number one you look up the path
and
off block x and it is let's call this
part p
and number two you read the path p into
your stash
and number three you try to write this
dash back to the same path
and what is key here is you try to pack
these blocks as close to the leaf as
possible
and this has to respect the invariant
remember not every block can go into the
leaf
depending on where the block is assigned
so if you have an a tree like this
and let's say this is my path
and i have my stash on the client side
so if a block is let's say
assigned to this
this subtree then this block cannot
go beyond this point on this path the
first furthest
the block can go is here
okay so based on this environment i'm
going to
try to pack the stuff that's in my stash
as close to the leaf as possible and i
write back
as many blocks as possible and
everything i failed to write back
still remain in the stash so will you
show an example
that's all you're going to say or you
will expand on this so
i can talk a little bit about the proof
intuition
but is the algorithm clear it's not
clear
oh okay so just use an example what's
this
example contents of the stash and what
happens to it when you
when you have fat people nothing is an
example
you have a block there it wants to go to
the blue triangle it goes down the path
and at some point it squeezes off of
those
angles
and so let's say you have a path
okay so this this is and this
corresponds to this path
i draw here and for simplicity let's
assume
and the bucket size is one okay and i
have some block
in my stash let's say there's just a
single block in my stash
and imagine this block is assigned
somewhere
in this subtree so let's say that this
block is assigned to this leaf
okay so i'm going to compute
and the um least
common ancestor of this path and the
current read path
which is this point okay
so in order to write this block back i'm
going to try to let's say this
this corresponds to this level so i will
first try to see
if this level is full if this level is
four it means i cannot write the block
here okay so this level is occupied this
level is occupied and this level is
occupied
so then i will try to write the block
into this level
and it still fails and then i try to
write the block
here and this level is empty so then the
block gets written to this level
so it's basically the in some sense it's
the most aggressive
eviction algorithm possible on a single
path
and it is usually you evict a previously
very big thing to the leaves and here
you try to evict
over the root it's like the opposite and
the
so this is the leaf just to be clear
this is the leaf this is the root
and i still let's say this block can
actually go into the leaf and the leaf
is empty
then i will end end up writing the block
into the leaf
so which means like remember in the
binary tree algorithm every time i just
evict one little step but here actually
the block can immediately be evicted to
the leaf
so you can basically evict many steps
and what if everything is full and then
then
stuff just remains in the stash and then
most
of the work of the skin is to basically
found the size of the stash
okay any other questions is the scheme
clear now
and no it actually it's
this is the next slide oh this is in a
couple more slides so the algorithm is
very simple and
you can write it in the three line
fashion you can also write it
a little bit more formally and this is
the pseudo code in our paper
it's basically 16 lines of pseudo code
and discount lines
such as ndif and n4 it's so simple you
can print it on a t-shirt
the measure is it whether you can tweet
it
good measure right yeah so you asked
about the stash
how big is the stash so we basically
formally proved that
the stash growth uh the probability that
the stash exceeds r is bounded by
something like an
e to the minus r
so how do you do the proof
i i can talk about the intuition
pretty quickly
okay so in order to do the proof we are
going to
um have an imaginary oram called the
infinity oram
and in the infinity oram every packet
is of infinite size so infinity orm is
actually not a secure orm scheme it's
just
a construct that that lives in the proof
for for bonding the
stash okay so now i'm going to run
the same path or path or ram
algorithm but on the infinity or ram
and in the infinity o ram because every
bucket
has infinite capacity and
a block is always in this case the least
common ancestor is here
so the block is always going to be
assigned to the least common ancestor
it's always going to be assigned to the
place uh
the furthest possible location the block
can go
um and in fact
it's not hard to relate
the stash size in the real patho ram and
to
some some characteristic
characterizations of the
this infinity or ram essentially we show
that
um if basically in the real oram
if your stash size is bounded by r
and that's equivalent to saying um
in the infinity or ram
so we are going to consider every
possible subtree
rooted at the root so the subtree can
have weird shapes like it can be like
some some tree like this
it can be a partial it doesn't have to
be a a complete
binary tree
so let's say this is the root
so this can be my sub tree
and the sub tree is basically part of
the bigger tree
okay so essentially if
for every sub tree um its usage is
bounded by
four times t is basically this this is
the size of the
the tree and then four is a a constant
that's related to the the bucket
bucket size so as long as the usage of
every sub tree is bounded by 40
plus r then this equates to saying that
this dash size
in the real oran is bounded by r
if you think about it it's actually
quite intuitive because um
essentially you can think of patho ram
as always evicting things to the
forget about the block size evicting
things to the furthest
location where it can go and then you
can do some kind of post processing to
pack things
um and repack things
uh to to satisfy the the bucket size
constraint
okay and then whatever overflows
overflows into the stash
okay so what's nice thing about what's
nice about this is now basically in
order to do the proof i only have to
reason about
this infinity or ram and this infiniti
orm is much easier to reason because
um i have this very nice property that
whenever a block gets invicted it will
go
to the place and the furthest place
it can legitimate legitimately reside so
there is actually
one version of patho ram that's
actually relatively easy to prove how
much time do i have
15 15 minutes um why don't i finish the
rest of the and do you want to listen to
the proof or go
go
and should i try to do the proof or
should i
go forward and maybe maybe if we have
more time at the end i can come back to
the proof
so there's basically one version of and
pathogram that's relatively easy to
prove
and i can explain the intuition in like
10 minutes or something
okay
that's what i wanted to say um the two
of you together
have two hours and 15. which is longer
than
two hours okay
so this version and of path around the
version of pathogram that's simplest to
prove
actually will rely on the eviction
technique and that's
introduced by gentry and mariana
maybe shy in the past 13 paper it's
called deterministic other
eviction and the idea is that
um in patho ram you evict on the read
path
so you read the pattern you evict on the
same path but you don't necessarily have
to do that
you can pick other parts to evict as
well so
in deterministic other eviction the idea
is that
and you are going to pick uh the paths
in a deterministic order
and specifically you will pick in you
know what's called
reverse and lexicographical order
and what this means is that you are
going to
write the the index of index of the leaf
node in binary format
and base 2 and then you
reverse these digits and that determines
the eviction order so what happens and
in practice is like basically you are
going to evict
the leftmost path first and then you are
going to evict
this path because this is like zero zero
zero
zero let's see and then this is a one
zero
zero zero and and then the next one
your evict will be uh
uh uh i'm fed
okay this one and so on so forth
so this eviction strategy has a very
nice property
and that um
so essentially i want to show that for
every sub
treaty uh the usage is going to be
bounded by 40
plus r but instead of so what's going to
happen is you are going to do a union
bound
all of the four to the uh four to uh
um there's four to the n
roughly speaking uh sub trees and you
are going to do a union bound on
all of these subtrees but instead of
considering apple tree sub trees
it's easier to consider subtrees that
are
um regular so that i'm only let's say
i'm only going to consider subtrees that
are flat
okay and i i'll explain the intuition
for these
flat subtrees and then you can kind of
extend the proof for arbitrary subtrees
okay so this is going to be my sub tree
and if your eviction order is follows
that deterministic other
eviction basically let's say i
evict this path
okay and the next the next time i come
back to evicting this path
will be exactly after let's
say this level has size two to the i so
after exactly two to the i steps
i will come back and then evict this
path again
okay so now i ask the question
how many blocks are in the subtree
okay and so let's consider and
every block as being assigned to one of
these
exit nodes at the boundary of the tree
um and in order to let's we can do an
expectation analysis
and then um it's not hard to show that
basically the number of blocks in
in this subtree is like some constant
times the size of the tree
and then if you know the expectation and
in order to prove a high probability
tailbone you just have to do something
like a channel bound
okay so how many blocks
um would remain that that are assigned
to
one specific exit node
in the subtree
um in the infinity o ram
every time i can come back to evict this
path
and then basically everything will be
evicted
away from because the buckets have
infinite size
so every time i basically evict this
part then things will
go out but in between these two
and evictions like 2 to the i time step
2 to the i time steps have a pass
okay and in every time step there's
roughly speaking two to the one over two
to the i probability that something will
be assigned
to this specific accent note so
times something like 2 to the i i'm i'm
emitting all the constants here so
basically you can show that
every accident node has about constant
number of
uh blocks assigned to it and then you
sum up all of these extra nodes
uh you get something like that's
basically constant times the size of the
tree
so it's basically the expectation
analysis is very simple and then you
just do a train of bound and you can
show
this high high probability tailbone
yeah why does it matter in which exact
order
i understand the deterministic but why
does it have to be reversed looks like a
graphic order
where does the order matter and you can
also do random
eviction it makes the proof a little
harder deterministic but why
you want this thing of coming back to
the node able to
be i think happened in every single uh
subtrees
and that's the only order that satisfies
that right right
in this case basically this after
exactly two to the i steps you'll come
back to evicting the same path
and that's why you can't do this very
simple
expectation analysis because in every
time step there's this much probability
that something will be assigned to this
accent node and then
over you know two to the i steps and you
get constant
number of things assigned to this action
node
okay
i guess from an intuitive perspective
like because
this path has the least overlap from
this path so
if you want to be aggressive like you
want to evict a path that has the least
overlap with
what has been previously evicted
okay so that's pathogram
and and patho ram is
great for implementing in secure
processors
and if you want to implement orm in
secure multiparty computation
things are a little different so rand
model com secure computation was first
proposed by
uh ostrovsky and shupe and then gordon
at all uh implemented um
ram model secure computation using the
binary trio ram in
2012 and then this is the
the latest result on malicious model uh
malicious secure
rand model competition and it appeared
in
europe 2015. okay
let me just understand so there is this
binary trio ram
there is bathroom and circuit over ram
and
i understand the chronological order but
i so my understanding is
the circuit is strictly better than thus
strictly better than binary trees so
circular ram is asymptotically from a
theoretical perspective circuit rm is
strictly better than python ramp from a
practical perspective if you want to
implement
insecure processors use a python ram is
a little better because
in patho ram you can afford to have the
cpu star like
let's say a log and size stash that's
not very expensive but
by having this little stash you can
shave constant factors of
the the data access axis
but strictly and then pass is strictly
better than binary three
yes and that is strictly better than
original rapid thing
the rafi um has lock lock cube too so
basically the binary tree
or ram it's a little complicated
basically for log n square block size
it's better for smaller block size and
the asymptotics are the same
but for the original hierarchical orm
you have to apply
this complex de-amortization cost a
de-amortization
scheme to get an a good
worst case cost because like if you just
implemented it's like sometimes you have
to take the whole memory and reshuffle
everything
so occasionally you are going to incur
linear cost
but there's a very nice demotization
trick that you can use
but still you know like state of the art
is a circuitry so if you use at least
from theoretical perspective
you don't need to know about other stuff
right um to understand circular ram
well i mean if you want to use it in
like let's say a theory paper or
something you just use certified you
don't need to know that
other stuff
okay all right so circuit auram and let
me explain uh
why we were motivated to study circuit
rm so we we implemented some of these
oram schemes in secure computation
and it turns out that oh so this is
actually
this is the secure processor figure so
in the secure processor case we can see
that patho ram
gives you the best bandwidth blow up
but when we implemented this on top of
mpc we noticed that patho ram is not
even as performant as binary tree o ram
and there's a reason why
because if you think about the patho
ramps eviction algorithm
this is difficult to implement as a
circuit like if you want to do mpc
everything has to be implemented in the
circuit
and the path around eviction algorithm
says you pack things as close to the
leaf as possible
so the naive way to implement this is to
do
a double loop like
i'm going to read one block
and in my stash and i'm going to look
over
uh all possible positions on the path
and evict that block
and then i'm going to grab another block
from my stash and i will look through
the whole path
and try to evict this next block but
this will incur like something like
log n squared overhead to implement
eviction algorithm
and and essentially the the problem is
that you have to make login scans
over this path and you don't want to do
that and there is actually there is a
way to make
the patho ram eviction algorithm
oblivious uh
using something like oblivious starting
but actually as we discovered this
the scheme we we tried the
the asymptotically better version of the
pathogram eviction
uh implemented as a circuit but actually
in most cases it doesn't perform
as well in practice as the naive
pathogen eviction
implemented as a circuit so this this
motivated us to look for a new algorithm
what was the why
basically now now we are in secure
computation land right so everything has
to be implemented as a circuit
so so in pathogram if you want to evict
the stash
onto your path you are going to the
naive way is to do
a double loop you say for every
block in your stash
and then you look at every position in
the on the path
for every position for every
let me call it for every slot
on the path p
and i'm going to try to
every slot let me call the slot s
i'm going to try to
write b
to location s
so this is the naive way to implement
um patho ram in a circuit
remember when you implement things in
the circuits you cannot make dynamic
memory accesses anymore
so essentially the algorithm has to be
oblivious
okay so this essentially this algorithms
will make log n scans over the past
and i i don't want to make log n scans
over the past it's too expensive
um
okay so what we really want is to be
able to
evict in a single data scan over the
past
okay so patho ram requires login data
scans over the past
how can we do it in a single data scan
so let's just try and i'm going to talk
about a broken idea
and okay so this again this is the root
and this is the leaf okay and i i will
try to evict things
upwards and arrow here
means so all of these
okay never mind so basically an arrow
here means that um
this red block can legitimately reside
in level two but not beyond
okay so this basically is a result of
the invariant
the main invariant of the scheme so now
i'm going to make one scan
over this path and as i scan
level 0 i'm going to pick up
this red block okay so and
if i'm greedy i'm going to try to pick
up a block that can be evicted the
furthest
furthest so pretend i'm going to be
greedy and do that
okay so now i go to level one and i have
to make a decision
whether to drop this block inside this
level
in this case obviously the best thing to
do is not to drop the block
in this level because the red block can
actually go to level two
the right thing to do is to write the
red block into level two
okay so in this case i happen to do the
right thing
but in an alternative world
you know everything in the starting
position is the same the only difference
is that in this case level two is
uh they are it's fully filled okay
in this alternative world
the right thing to do what's going on
the right thing to do is to pick up the
red block and then write it to level one
so i should not have held on to this
block if because when i
scan level one because if i held onto
this block later i'm going to discover
that
there's no place for me to write this
block anymore so i end up holding this
block and then
and there's nothing i can do with it
anymore
and the problem basically is lack of
foresight
when i start the scan i don't have any
insight on
when i should pick up a block and when i
should write a block
so therefore the idea is very simple we
are just going to do two metadata scans
to develop the inside that's necessary
and to to eventually do this data scan
in one shot so i'm not going to describe
the algorithm in detail i'm going to
play this
animation okay to start with
basically these blue blocks and
are the ones that can be evicted further
within the same
level okay so every level has two blocks
and
in this case this blue block can be
evicted further than the black block
um okay and in the first
metadata scan i'm going to develop these
blue arrows which is my method data and
then in the second
metadata scan path i'm going to develop
these
green arrows and this green arrow
essentially provides a recipe
on what to do when i do the full data
scan
so so eventually when i actually start
doing the full data scan i'm just going
to follow the
the green arrows and this provides a
recipe on what to do so
essentially here i pick up a block and
the green arrow says i should
put it in level one so i do that but i
i pick up another block from level one
and then according to the green arrow i
should
put it in level three so i do that but i
pick up a blocking level three at the
same time
and then this goes on so then i complete
the full
data scan yes what if you
what if you just tried to do a
randomized thing and at every level you
flip a coin if it's heads
place it if it's tails you carry it i i
i
i don't think the stash will be bounded
i i
we that's just i'm not sure if we tried
many different things
we basically tried uh maybe like 20 or
30 different schemes and
initially a variant of this worked but
we couldn't improve it and then
we modified the scheme randomized
without any metadata
i uh my my gut feeling is that the the
stash won't be bonded
because the thing is actually pretty
tricky to to make it work we try lots of
different things like
i i'm sure we try ideas like this one
you're not actually implementing the
most aggressive uh eviction
from the platform this is a different
eviction structure it could not
necessarily push everything as far as it
can go
right right so this is a milder eviction
it's not the same as pathology
but speaking of most aggressive it is
not the most
aggressive eviction scheme over the past
but it is the most
aggressive eviction uh restricted to a
single data scan
so that that's another way to think
about it this is the theorem that he
proves
uh we didn't prove this but if you think
about it
and that that's the best thing because
it's kind of like saying uh have you
looked at in hindsight would you
what what would you have done right to
evict this
and it is this i mean to formally show
it you have to
define what is most aggressive but if
you really want to formalize this
you can and it's still
constant yeah
it still comes in size buckets and the
proof
kind of follows the same overall
framework
as patho ram where we kind of
prove things in this infiniti oram world
except that in this case improving
equivalence to the in
infinity orm is a very very complicated
and
induction proof like in the case of
pathogram proving equivalence to the
infinity oram is very simple it's a
simple
simple uh inductive proof in this case
actually
i didn't believe it was equivalent uh in
the beginning and i
i argued back and forth with my
co-author hubert and he believed it was
true and
in the end we proved that it was true it
was it was very subtle like um
just to understand in terms of eviction
strategies this is
strictly less aggressive than pathogen
but you're saving time by like shaving a
log factor or something right so this is
kind of
you hope it's faster you you hope to
lose like maybe only a constant factor
in terms of aggressiveness and
a lot of gain low factor in terms of
speed
and so so you have to be a little
careful here
from an asymptotical perspective patho
ram can be
patho ramps eviction can be implemented
with the
log and log log n circuit using oblivion
starting
but it's just that that is in practice
is not even as
efficient as that double loop double
loop thing and here you can do it
basically a log and size circuit
because the so so the metadata scan and
a constant number of metadata scans but
also another practical saving you get is
that the metadata scan
need not touch the real data blocks so
typically if your data blocks
are much bigger than your metadata then
you also get a constant factor there
stash size is the same in both cases
it's like logan or something
yes the stash size and the asymptotical
distribution is like is similar
basically the probability the stash
exceeds r
is proportional to like e to the minus r
is there any reason we want an
aggressive eviction strategy except that
it will
enable bounding the stash size uh we
want it to be
because like in the binary tree orm the
bucket sizes are login
and that introduces another
question is given two schemes that have
the same bucket and stash size
one with an aggressive eviction strategy
and or less aggressive equations
it doesn't matter right it doesn't
matter but
except that for patho ram it's good for
the secure processor but it's not very
good for
mpc uh type of con benchmarks where you
have to implement the eviction
algorithm as a circuit like not in the
real model typically when we think about
algorithms like we
usually think of it in the ram model
where you know you have a cpu accessing
memory and you express your algorithms
complexity in the ram model that's what
the algorithms community
does but in the mpc world everything has
to be expressing
circuit complexity okay
okay so i'm going to just quickly wrap
up uh
when we implement circuit orm in
circuits it's roughly
it gives you like 50x smaller circuits
than patho ram
and the break even point with linear
scan oram
is very small like basically one
kilobytes
which means if your payload is 32 bits
like a 32-bit integer
if your array size is only 256 entries
you are better off using
circuit or ram in comparison with linear
scan or ram
okay so just i'm going to quickly talk
about some of the recent results in this
space
and new models for oblivious ram
and so elect kami and rafael has
oblivious parallel ram and in this case
instead of having a single cpu you have
um and and cpus
and then they're accessing the memory in
parallel so they have a very nice scheme
that can do that
and then this can be this is an a
building block that's used to design
their
large scale secure computation paper
okay and then we also have a resultant
oblivious
network ram where within each memory
bank
the the adversary cannot observe the
offset within each memory bank
but the adversary can observe which
memory bank you go to
so this is a this work shows some
interesting
um connections to the parallel
algorithms literature
like we use some non very nice
known results from the parallel
algorithms literature that gives you
these
log star and algorithms so that's why
our paper has blocked that end
which makes it cool okay
and then and also related is oblivious
algorithms and parallel oblivious
algorithms
if you see a paper um that's something
like secure computation for task
x uh chances are this is an oblivious
algorithm paper
and these papers are concerned these
works are basically
concerned about taking a specific task
and express this as an oblivious
algorithm so oblivious algorithm
and circuits are
in some sense translatable so if you
want to implement anything on top of mpc
you have to express it as a circuit
which means you have to express it as an
oblivious algorithm
okay so we we have been developing
programming language
frameworks to make tasks like this
easier
and so so essentially a lot of
cryptographic primitives rely on
expressing
programs as circuits and in these cases
uh all ram
and oblivious algorithms would be
relevant
okay and then there are in the in the
systems and programming language
and literature people have worked on
programming frameworks
that helped this program to circuit
conversion
and this actually occurred in both the
secure
computation context and the verifiable
computation context
there are similarities between these two
lines of research but they are also
different
in the sense that in mpc you have to
express the circuit
in circuit the task you want to compute
whereas in verifiable computation you're
expressing
a circuit this basically the
the program for checking that the
computation is correct
so so this uh checking that the
computation is correct in some sense
it's a lot easier than
uh expressing the the computation itself
in circuit
but nevertheless like if you look at
these works like they also kind of rely
on oblivious algorithms like oblivious
sorting
and to to do this and to
express this as a circuit
okay so we we have been building this
framework of lvm i guess chun
chung is here are you here no
and and we basically help
the non-specialist programmer you know
can write a program
and then we compile it into a oblivious
counterpart and then
our compiler actually has been
integrated with both the oram-based
secure processor
and on top of a secure computation
backhand
and so this is pretty cool like for
instance and
like two years ago if you were to
implement
matrix factorization design a customized
oblivious algorithm for matrix
factorization or ritual regression this
would have taken you months
to accomplish but with our framework you
can do the same task like in one day
and we achieve better performance
and actually the framework we our
framework provides
programming abstractions so if you write
your program
in our oblivious programming
abstractions we admit to oblivious
algorithms that are competitive to the
custom designs
and our programming framework can type
check that our program
indeed satisfies a blue business and
what is more cool is that we had these
programming abstractions and we are
composing them
to write new algorithms and what was
surprising to us is that
by doing so we have happened to just
happen to solve some open
problems in oblivious algorithm design
we realize the thing we end up with is
actually more efficient
than any oblivious algorithm known
previously
so what's the simplest example of an
oblivious cell grid and what do you mean
uh so let's say you want to have an um
shortest path on sparse graphs
you can write this program very easily
using our programming framework
and we offer several programming
abstractions one is called the loop
coalescing
abstraction and we think about the
programming abstraction as mapreduce i'm
not producing is a programming paradigm
so we offer several of these like one is
oblivious data structure and the other
is
loop coalescing and if you were to
implement
and shortest path in our framework the
easiest
thing to do is to you take one of these
loop coalescing abstractions and you
combine it with oblivious data structure
like diaxtra has this oblivious heap
thing right
and then we basically implement the
scene and now we realize actually the
resulting algorithm is
asymptotically more efficient for sparse
graphs then than previously known
algorithms
like oblivious rams here this is like
dedicated oblivious algorithms
and so our framework falls back to
oblivious ram and
so we provide general generality but
if you use any of our programming
abstractions we can do optimizations and
emit oblivious algorithms
instead of generic orang so we kind of
want to provide
the best of both worlds both the
generality and the efficiency of
customized algorithms
so this is around this secure processor
does it
what does it do does it compute the same
circuit then you would also don't use it
for the speed computation or uh the
secure processor implements the oram
controller
and on chip what is our
control oh um oram controller is the
oram algorithm
if you were to implement it on top of an
a secure processor the orm algorithm has
to be trusted
so it has to be implemented on chip
so basically this programming framework
i can talk about it for another hour but
of course i'm not going to do that
thank you and
a bunch of us are going to and go and
go boating in this park in mountain view
on sunday if you want to join us please
let me know
this was one of my favorite places in
the bay area
is it going to be oblivious
so i'm sure you'll be happy to take that
question
yes let's tank